what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we have some major
Marvel news to go over today especially
concerning the Fantastic 4 the last we
heard about the casting of the Fantastic
4 came from Matt shakman himself and he
said that we should know the casting of
the Fantastic 4 soon speaking about us
the audience should know soon the fans
should know soon because they're about
to make everything official at Marvel
Studios for the official cast Matt
shakman pretty much said that when the
strikes are over not too long after
we're going to find out who the cast is
and guess what the strikes are over and
it looks like we know who our Mr
Fantastic is going to be and this name
is coming out of left field you probably
already know cuz I probably put it in
the title but Pedro Pascal has been
offered the role from Marvel Studios to
play Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic of
the Fantastic 4 now we have some other
major Marvel news to talk about in this
video but a lot is happening with the
Fantastic 4 right now this report that
Pedro Pascal has been offered the role
of Reed Richards for Marvel Studios is
coming from Insider Daniel rpk it's also
been backed up by others as well Grace
Randolph posted when this report
happened well Reed Richards is a daddy
looking into this Pedro Pascal rumor of
the Fantastic 4 and then she updated it
with update it's true he has the offer
but hasn't accepted yet and now even
huge media Outlets like deadline have
reported things like this after months
of speculation of who might play Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic in Marvel
studios's highly anticipated fantastic
for pick the wait may be finally over
while a deal is far from done sources
tell deadline Pedro Pascal is in the
talks to play the role so we have some
big insiders confirming this and now a
huge media Outlet is confirming this so
needless to say it's all true Marvel has
offered the role officially to Pedro
Pascal and go ahead and let me know
right away do you think that's a good
call do you like that I personally love
Pedro Pascal as an actor and I will say
I think he is in a good age range to
play read in the MCU especially if you
consider what we heard what we've heard
about the Fantastic 4 is that when the
Fantastic 4 team gets introduced to the
MCU Reed and Sue are already going to be
married and they're going to be parents
so again I think his age range is really
good but at the same time I do think he
has a really good look to play Mr
Fantastic I really do and of course he
is a phenomenal actor there's no doubt
that he would do an incredible job I do
wholeheartedly believe that but here's a
big question would he go well with
Vanessa Kirby as Sue storm as his wife
in the MCU because based off of
everything that we've learned and that
we know Vanessa Kirby is our Sous storm
they offered her the contract before the
strikes began and from what we've heard
she accepted it so how do we think
Vanessa Kirby and Pedro Pascal would
work together what would the chemistry
be like do we think that it would be
good and do they look good together I
personally think yeah this could
definitely work because the both of them
the two of them are incredible actors if
you haven't seen what they've done I
suggest you look into their shows and
their movies because truly they can act
very well now the last we heard Jake
Gyllenhaal was offered the role of Mr
Fantastic of the Fantastic 4 which had
some controversy surrounding it
obviously since he played Mysterio in
the MCU but I should specify he played
Mysterio in the
616 Universe in the MCU from what we've
heard the Fantastic 4 film might
actually take place in Another Universe
and it might take place in the 60s so
that could explain how Jake Gyllenhaal
could play Reed Richards but also
Mysterio at the same time however it
still does get a little bit messy so I
got to say even though I do love Jake
Gyllenhaal and I wish he was still in
the MCU I think going with Pedro pasca
would be the better option but again let
me know your thoughts now as far as Kang
Dynasty is concerned we've heard a lot
about it we recently heard that they
dropped one of the writers because they
might be moving away from Kang be moving
away from the Kang storyline altogether
but now we have heard that the director
is gone now this report is also coming
from deadline and they State Destin
Daniel keton departs as director on
Avengers the King Dynasty and if you are
not aware Destin Daniel keton directed
shangqi and the legend of the tin Rings
which was awesome he did a fantastic job
and he's very passionate about his work
I've spoken to him several times
including an interview I did with him
for shangi and Marvel Studios seems to
really like him as well as deadline
reports he remains aboard Wonderman
shangqi 2 and more in the MCU so clearly
Marvel Studios really really likes
director Dustin Daniel keton so much
that they are keeping him around even
though he is no longer on the King
Dynasty so the big question is why why
is he no longer on the King Dynasty well
from what we have heard and you have
probably heard this already Jeff lovess
who was the writer for Avengers King
Dynasty and who also wrote Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania has recently been
taken off of that project and the
reported reason coming from Joanna
Robinson the author of MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios he is off the project
because they are moving in a different
direction and the direction that they
are moving from is Kang they might be
moving away from Kang the Conqueror in
the MCU and of course if they do that
then they wouldn't have Kang Dynasty
that is supposedly why these people are
no longer attached to the project and if
we think about it this new report kind
of helps it all make sense deadline
reports that he's off the project but
he's still on other Marvel projects he's
on multiple ones more than two more than
three it sounds like so this further
backs up that report that they are
simply going to change what the movie is
going to be about that's why they don't
have the same writer that's why they
don't have the same director because
what they had hired them to do they are
no longer doing it they specifically
hired Jeff lovess who introduced the
true king the Conqueror to us in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania hired him to
continue to handle Kang the Conqueror in
the MCU which would include his variants
which of course we saw in the post
credits for Quantum Mania and then they
took Dustin Daniel keton who did an
amazing job with shangqi talked to him
about Kang and said all right cool
you're going to be our guy for Kang
Dynasty they specifically hired him to
direct a story about Kang which may no
longer be the case which may be why he
is no longer attached to that project so
as sad as it is we might actually be
moving away from Kang in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but that would mean
Doom would come into the MCU as has been
reported by variety they stated that
Marvel Studios was considering moving
away from King and bringing in Dr Doom
that of course is not confirmed but it
now seems like we are getting close
closer to that being an actual reality
I'm sure when we hear about who they get
to be the new writer and the new
director for this film it'll start to
really give us an idea of what exactly
is going to happen and I'm curious who
they would get to direct a movie about
doom and if you're wondering well how
exactly would they step away from Kang
when he's been built up so much
especially with Loki season 2 recently
happening well Loki season 2 kind of
opened it up for Marvel to replace Kang
if they needed Loki made the Multiverse
a reality he made it possible and he
made it possible for the Multiverse to
exist while people have free will and
now the TVA has one job monitor every
timeline for Kang for variants of he who
remains so unfortunately and I say
unfortunately because I do think
Jonathan major did an amazing job as
Kang the Conqueror and I do hope he's
innocent and if he is I hope they
continue with him however again
unfortunately the Loki finale opened
Marvel Studios up to actually replace
him because now if you replace him all
you have to do is say yeah the TVA took
care of Kang and they continue to take
care of him thanks to the TVA there is
no multiversal war because they prune
every Kang variant not a timeline but
him specifically from the timeline and
Dr Doom is a genius he's one of the
smartest people in Marvel history ever
so it's not that hard to say he gets his
hands on some Kang time travel
technology and all of a sudden he's the
big multiversal threat it is definitely
possible but go ahead and let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and of course what
you think about the Fantastic Four News
as well please give the video a like And
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on the MCU and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof